federal investigators are looking into
how the FAA approved Boeing 737 max jet
after similarities were found in two
deadly crashes in less than five months
Boeing's the CEO released a video last
night insisting the company's planes are
safe and he pledged a new software
update would address safety concerns
Kris Van Cleave is at Washington's
Reagan National Airport Chris good
morning good morning that software
update is aimed at addressing issues
with an anti stall system that is being
looked at as a factor in the lion air
737 max crash back in October this as
investigators in Ethiopia are continuing
to analyze data from the second max
crash but say there are clear
similarities we joined the world with
heavy hearts in grieving after offering
his condolences to victims of the two
Boeing 737 max crashes CEO Dennis
Muhlenberg reiterated his company's
commitment to safety in a recorded video
when an accident happens for any reason
we focused relentlessly to determine why
in addition to a new software update
Boeing will update training requirements
for the 737 max captain Dennis Taser has
flown the max for American Airlines
he says pilots want a role in what comes
next we want our experts in whatever
simulator you can find so that we and
our pilots can feel confident that we
have all the information but questions
remain about the relationship between
Boeing and the FAA federal authorities
have told employees at Boeing and the
FAA to retain documents relating to the
planes approval process which by design
relies on manufacturers like Boeing to
self-police
that they've met FAA requirements Scott
Brenner a former associate administrator
at the FAA says the agency does not have
the resources to certify aircraft
without the help of the manufacturer on
some level the FAA is taking Boeing's
word for a lot of this they are taking
Boeing's work but they Boeing is also
presenting data to prove their work as
far back as 1993 the Government
Accountability Office warned FAA
certification staff were falling far
behind industry and technical competency
in part because of delegating to
manufacturers former NTSB Chairman James
Hall we need to wake up the regulators
and we need to
put a VA ssin safety first now this
certification process has been in use
for decades but after 9/11 Congress and
the FAA allowed businesses to do more of
the safety approval process themselves
the software update is expected to be
approved by the FAA by Monday it's
unclear if that will be enough to lift
the order grounding the max gale alright
thank you very much Chris